what up guys first and foremost we want
to thank everyone that has supported us
on patreon for the last couple of years
if you didn't even know that we had a
patreon you're gonna want to listen to
this because this year we thought of a
bunch of different ways to bring us all
closer together yup we've completely
reorganized the tiers so that we can get
closer and interact more with each other
starting with our first tier only
friends you get access to our private
Discord which means we get to chat every
single day how you doing you can ask us
any question on whatever you want and if
the question is good enough to turn into
a full-blown YouTube video we're gonna
give you a shout out at the end yo Roy
good job
in this chair you also get to watch our
patreon live stream recordings after we
record them and the public doesn't get
to do that and of course just like
always every once in a while a video
that's too crazy for YouTube our second
tier is only homies you obviously get
all the above plus you get to tune in to
the patreon live stream live as it's
happening this is gonna be exclusive to
only homies that tune in while it's
happening and watch it like a live
audience wow our highest tier is Only
Lovers not only do you get all of the
above but you can actually participate
in the live stream where we video chat
with each other in real time also since
you're a lover you get to kick it with
JK for a day after being a lover for 12
months you can get a private tour of all
of our Brands like barbell joombie or
join us on our next JK Adventure you'll
also be named as a producer in the
credits for loving us so much as you you
guys know our patreon members has helped
us so much through all of our ups and
downs especially dealing with YouTube
after all these years so we wanted to
find more ways to return that love yeah
we really appreciate you guys if you
want to get closer to us and support hit
the link in the description and go to
our patreon thank you for all the love
and we'll continue to provide you with
laughter all year long
and if not stay on YouTube don't matter
have a good time